programming throwdown episode 72 internationalization take it away jason hey everyone so uh this is the last show before our december uh prize giveaway it's our second annual prize giveaway so last time we gave away i think three t-shirts um so every time we try and do a little bit more. Thanks everyone for donating, all our patrons. We put that money to the server costs, to advertising, to get the word out, all of that. But every year,
Programming Throwdown 第 72 期，国际化。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，这是我们 12 月奖品赠送活动前的最后一期节目。这是我们举办的第二届年度奖品赠送活动，上次我们送出了大概三件 T 恤，所以我们每次都想做得更好一点。感谢大家的捐赠，感谢我们所有的赞助人。我们将这些钱用于服务器成本、广告宣传、扩大影响力等等。但每年，
we have some left over and we figure out a way to give that money back to you through prizes. So this year, we had a little bit more left over and we also want to do something really cool. So we're actually going to figure out a way to get a prize to everybody um so it's going to work like
我们都会剩下一些钱，于是我们想出了一种方式，通过奖品把这些钱回馈给你们。所以今年，我们剩下的钱多了一点，我们也想做一些非常酷的事情。我们实际上打算想办法给每个人都送一份奖品，所以运作方式是这样的：
this um uh to all our patreon we're going to give out the three t-shirts yeah yeah to everyone who's signed up through patreon and supported us um so we'll get uh three people get a t-shirt just like last year. I'm also going to 3D printed some pretty cool things. So three people are going to get this really cool screw puzzle. If you don't know what that is, it's basically you get these pieces and they all look kind of goofy. But if you kind of turn them a certain way, then it makes this really cool shape and it kind of everything kind of locks into place. So I've printed three of those. I've also printed three fractal pyramids,
嗯，对于我们所有的 Patreon 赞助人，我们会送出那三件 T 恤，是的，给所有在 Patreon 上注册并支持我们的人。所以我们会选出三个人获得 T 恤，就像去年一样。我还打算用 3D 打印一些很酷的东西。所以有三个人会得到这个非常酷的螺丝拼图。如果你不知道那是什么，基本上就是你得到这些看起来有点笨拙的零件，但如果你以某种方式转动它们，它就会形成一个非常酷的形状，而且所有东西都会锁定到位。所以我打印了三个。我还打印了三个分形金字塔，
which are pretty cool. If you haven't seen them, just kind of imagine, you know, like the Sierpinski triangle, but in 3D. So three people will get that. And everyone else who is a patron of ours we're going to figure out a way to mail you something so we're figuring out now whether it's going to be some type of like 3d printed badge or a laser cut uh logo or something like that i'm actually going to design it tonight or tomorrow and i will try out a few designs um ourselves before december
它们非常酷。如果你还没见过，想象一下谢尔宾斯基三角形，但它是 3D 的。所以三个人会得到那个。而我们所有的其他赞助人，我们会想办法给你们邮寄一些东西，我们现在正在考虑是某种 3D 打印的徽章，还是激光切割的标志之类的东西。我今晚或明天就会设计它，在 12 月之前我们会自己先试做几个设计。
um but uh yeah we're gonna figure out a way to get something to everybody um people who signed up uh like early patrons might have not put their address so i changed patreon about six months ago to require an address um but if you signed up early, you might have not given us your address. So please go in and put in your address or put in something like don't mail me anything. And we know not to not to pick you as one of the winners. But but yeah, that would help us out a lot. Otherwise, we have to kind of, you know, email you and track you down and and and wait for you to email us back and all of that so so that's the giveaway pretty excited oh the last thing we're going to uh stream the whole thing live on twitch um and maybe other things too like i don't know facebook live i don't know if we could do all of them at the same time maybe i'll figure that out uh we're going to stream it live i'll let
嗯，但我们会想办法给每个人都送点东西。那些很早就注册的赞助人可能没有填写地址，所以我大约六个月前更改了 Patreon 的设置，要求必须填写地址。但如果你注册得早，可能没有给我们地址。所以请进去填一下你的地址，或者填上类似“不要给我邮寄任何东西”之类的话。这样我们就知道不要把你选为获奖者之一。但这真的会帮我们大忙。否则，我们还得给你发邮件，追踪你，等着你回复邮件等等。所以这就是赠送活动，很兴奋。哦，最后一件事，我们会在 Twitch 上直播整个过程，也许还有其他平台，比如 Facebook Live，我不知道我们能不能同时在所有平台上直播，也许我会研究一下。我们会进行直播，我会
you know more of the details when we have them. But stay tuned. Follow us on Google+, Facebook, Twitter. I'll post all of them. LinkedIn. All the regular places I post the show updates. I'll let everyone know when and where we will be streaming live. You feel like a good old Santa Claus now, huh? That's right. Yeah yeah hopefully you folks get this in time for christmas it'd be pretty awesome all right put some put some programming throw down in the stocking now that everyone feels in the holiday spirit we'll do our news wait it's but it's not it's not our december show so okay anyways um my first link is uh an sqlite sqlite uh three tutorial and guide uh this was an article i saw recently and as i come across stuff i try to just sort of
在有更多细节时通知你们。请保持关注。在 Google+、Facebook、Twitter 上关注我们。我会发布所有这些信息。还有 LinkedIn。所有我发布节目更新的常规平台。我会让大家知道我们何时何地进行直播。你现在感觉像个老圣诞老人了，对吧？没错。希望你们能及时收到这些礼物，那会很棒。好了，现在把 Programming Throwdown 放进袜子里吧。既然大家都感受到了节日气氛，我们来播报新闻。等等，这不是我们的 12 月节目，所以……好吧，总之，我的第一个链接是一个 SQLite 3 教程和指南。这是我最近看到的一篇文章，当我遇到好东西时，我尽量把它
squirrel it away um but this one is going over how to use sqlite and although the article is is quite good um i'm sure there are many other articles as well in SQLite 3. I wanted to use it as a sort of pseudo tool of the show to be able to talk about how good SQLite is. And it's actually really commonly used. But if you've never used it before, check out this tutorial, check out SQLiteite 3 it has lots of really good features and you can find all sorts of people using it in all kinds of projects i know like a lot of mobile mobile apps use sqlite for database storage engine people use it you know to sort of serve up on stuff on the web you know to sort of have a a backend server that uses, if your data
存起来。但这一篇是关于如何使用 SQLite 的，虽然这篇文章写得很好，但我相信关于 SQLite 3 还有很多其他文章。我想把它作为一个节目的伪工具，来谈谈 SQLite 有多好。它实际上非常常用。但如果你从未使用过它，看看这个教程，看看 SQLite 3，它有很多非常好的功能，你可以在各种项目中找到很多人在使用它。我知道很多移动应用程序使用 SQLite 作为数据库存储引擎，人们用它来在网络上提供服务，或者拥有一个后端服务器。如果你的数据
is not so big that you need a kind of fully distributed data store, uh, SQLite three scales pretty well. Um, and so you can use it for quite a lot of data. Um, but I guess it's the classic, your data is not really as big as you think it is kind of thing. Like try it until it doesn't work. And then when it doesn't work you can you know invest the effort of trying to use something else yeah so for people who don't know sqlite basically it has the full ansi sql syntax you could do selects you could do joins you do all that stuff just if you're writing to like a mysql database or something like that but the entire database is just one file on your computer um so you know it's it's
没有大到需要一个完全分布式的数据库，SQLite 3 的扩展性相当不错。所以你可以用它处理相当多的数据。但我猜这就是经典的“你的数据其实没你想的那么大”的情况。试用它，直到它无法工作。当它无法工作时，你再去投入精力尝试使用其他东西。是的，对于那些不知道 SQLite 的人来说，它基本上拥有完整的 ANSI SQL 语法，你可以进行 SELECT、JOIN 等操作，就像你在编写 MySQL 数据库或其他类似数据库时一样，但整个数据库只是你电脑上的一个文件。所以你知道，它
super cool super portable it works anywhere and actually the entire source code of sqlite is just one file which is pretty amazing or horrifying i'll go yeah going with amazing actually i think it's uh it's actually a bunch of files but then they have an amalgamation tool, which turns it into one file. Okay, I was going to say, that sounds like something you just script. Yeah, yeah. Cool.
超级酷，超级便携，可以在任何地方运行。实际上，SQLite 的整个源代码只是一个文件，这非常令人惊叹，或者说令人恐惧。我会说，是的，令人惊叹。其实它是一堆文件，但他们有一个合并工具，把它变成了一个文件。好吧，我本来想说，这听起来像是你可以用脚本处理的东西。是的，是的。酷。
Yeah, SQLite's awesome. The tutorial, I'm sure it's really useful. Both of us have used SQLite a ton, so it's super important. Definitely take a look at it. If you're writing massive JSON filesson files that are like you know half a gig or something you probably need to be using sqlite um depending on circumstance but i mean i guess that's a good segue i work with a lot of people who have never used sql before
是的，SQLite 很棒。这个教程我相信非常有用。我们俩都大量使用过 SQLite，所以它非常重要。一定要看一看。如果你正在编写巨大的 JSON 文件，比如半个 G 之类的，你可能需要使用 SQLite，具体取决于情况。但我想这是一个很好的过渡，我和很多从未使用过 SQL 的人一起工作，
and i actually hadn't until uh my previous job and then i used it and i realized how much i had been avoiding it like how often it actually comes up and is important to know. So I did it a little bit in college, but not enough to really understand it. And then I started using it more and more. And it's something that if you've avoided it, don't avoid it. It's actually very important to learn. It's a good tool to have. And you can probably get away avoiding it, or at least i did for a while but eventually
其实我在上一份工作之前也没用过。后来我用了它，才意识到我之前避开了它多久，意识到它实际上是多么重要。我在大学里学过一点，但不够深入，无法真正理解。后来我开始越来越多地使用它。如果你一直避开它，不要再避开了。学习它非常重要。这是一个很好的工具。你可能可以暂时避开它，或者至少我有一段时间是这样，但最终
you're gonna want to know how to use it yeah i mean i probably well it depends on the time of year i mean time of the project and stuff but there are times where i spend just all day just doing sql um because you just it's it's the best for organizing data, transforming data, things like that. It's just, it makes life really, really easy. Cool. My news is mask our CNN in TensorFlow. So I'll explain what that is. So CNN is convolutional neural network. I'm not gonna go into too much detail on what that is,
你会想要知道如何使用它。是的，我的意思是，这取决于一年中的时间，取决于项目的进度等等，但有时我整天都在写 SQL，因为它是组织数据、转换数据等方面的最佳选择。它让生活变得非常、非常简单。酷。我的新闻是 TensorFlow 中的 Mask R-CNN。我会解释那是什么。CNN 是卷积神经网络。我不会详细介绍那是什么，
but let's just say it's really good for handling images. Our CNN is, I think it's like a recurrent. I actually don't know off the top of my head what the R stands for. Probably recurrent, but I could be wrong on that. And then the mask part is basically, think of it as sort of like a set of tiles in the image they're sort of sliding over and uh super super glossing over all the details but check out this link um basically it's for image object detection and recognition images so you can give it an image with a bunch of different objects there's like a person walking on the street and a traffic light in a car
但我们只需说它非常擅长处理图像。R-CNN 是，我想它是某种循环（recurrent）。其实我一时想不起来 R 代表什么。可能是循环，但我可能记错了。然后 Mask 部分基本上可以把它想象成图像中的一组瓦片，它们在上面滑动。我略过了所有细节，但请查看这个链接。它基本上用于图像对象检测和识别。所以你可以给它一张有很多不同对象的图像，比如街上走着一个人，还有一个交通灯和一辆车，
and it will say hey there's a person and a traffic light and a car, and it will say, hey, there's a person and a traffic light and a car, and here's where they are, and here's their bounding box, and this is their label. So, you know, you can imagine, like, regular image processing, where, you know, you give it a bunch of digits, right, zero through nine digits, and then you give it another digit and it says oh that's a seven right but what if you gave it you know a book full of digits like a book full of numbers that's a much much different problem because you have to turn that page to turn that that image of that book you know pull out all of the individual numbers, like know they're there, pull them out, and then run that first step, which says whether it's a seven or an eight, right?
它会说：“嘿，有一个人、一个交通灯和一辆车。”它会告诉你它们在哪里，它们的边界框是什么，以及它们的标签。所以，你可以想象，就像常规的图像处理，你给它一堆数字，比如 0 到 9 的数字，然后你给它另一个数字，它会说“哦，那是 7”。但如果你给它一本全是数字的书呢？那是一个完全不同的问题，因为你必须翻开那一页，把那本书的图像中的所有单个数字提取出来，知道它们在那里，把它们取出来，然后运行第一步，判断它是 7 还是 8，对吧？
So it's pretty complicated stuff. The cool thing about this is that it's totally open source and it actually comes with the data. So it's not like one of these things where, you know, you're just never gonna be able to run it. Like if you just follow the instructions, you actually download the data, build the model, and you'll be able to detect like cars and traffic lights and stuff like that. Sheep, donuts. Pretty cool.
所以这非常复杂。这个东西很酷的地方在于它是完全开源的，而且它实际上附带了数据。所以它不像那种你永远无法运行的东西。如果你按照说明操作，你实际上可以下载数据，构建模型，然后你就能检测到汽车、交通灯之类的东西。羊、甜甜圈。很酷。
Sheep and donuts? That's a thing. I don't know. It's at the bottom of the examples. Oh, okay. Nice. But yeah, and it goes into tremendous detail it's it's really really cool and uh if nothing else you can just run the lines they tell you to and you'll get
羊和甜甜圈？那是真的吗？我不知道。它在示例的底部。哦，好吧。不错。但它确实非常详细，非常非常酷。如果什么都不做，你至少可以运行他们告诉你的代码行，你最终会得到
this really cool thing at the end so so uh check it out yeah this seems like a like even more so than you were saying like uh character, sort of recognizing occluded objects, generating the mask for them. So not just saying, is there a person in this image, but where are they and exactly what shape are they? Yep. That seems really tough. Yeah, it's pretty amazing. As Patrick said, it handles occlusion. So you could have a person and you could have
这个非常酷的东西。所以，去看看吧。是的，这看起来比你说的还要厉害，比如识别被遮挡的对象，为它们生成掩码。所以不仅仅是说图像里有没有人，而是他们在哪里，形状到底是什么样的？是的。这看起来很难。是的，非常惊人。正如 Patrick 所说，它处理遮挡。所以你可以有一个人，然后你可以在人前面放一个
a stop sign in front of the person and it'll actually handle that. Like basically it will remove the stop sign or it'll just kind of like... Yeah, I don't actually know... I'm not an image processing guy, so I don't know a lot about how it actually works under the hood. But it can actually say, oh, these pixels probably don't belong to this person. And so it says, I don't know what these pixels really are, but I know these pixels around are like this. And then it can say, oh, that's a person. Because even though there's all these non-person pixels there, I know that it's sort of a segment, a different segment.
停车标志，它实际上能处理这种情况。基本上它会移除停车标志，或者它只是……是的，我其实不知道……我不是图像处理专家，所以我不知道它在底层是如何工作的。但它实际上可以说：“哦，这些像素可能不属于这个人。”所以它说：“我不知道这些像素到底是什么，但我知道周围的这些像素是这样的。”然后它就能说：“哦，那是一个人。”因为即使那里有所有这些非人的像素，我也知道它是一个片段，一个不同的片段。
So it does a lot of complicated stuff. And like a lot of things, neural networks have sort of automated a lot of the human engineering, which is pretty remarkable. And that trend continues. But yeah, check this out. I thought it was pretty amazing to look at.
所以它做了很多复杂的事情。像许多事情一样，神经网络已经自动化了很多人类工程，这非常了不起。这种趋势还在继续。但是的，去看看这个。我觉得看这个非常令人惊叹。
That's pretty cool. My next article asks the question, do you have learner's syndrome? They admit right off the bat that learner's syndrome is not really a thing. And they proceed to point out something that I've thought about a fair amount, especially, you know, now that I've been working as a software engineer for too long. And, you know, you see people come in and they're all excited and gung ho and they feel like they have the solution to everything. Right. Or what if we only just use this technology or use that technology and most we've talked about you know various languages before that that are you know three decades old or more uh oh four decades wow i can't believe it's 2017 um anyways it's and so we use like c++ and although we use you C++ 11, almost 14, even that is buggy.
那很酷。我的下一篇文章提出了一个问题：你有“学习者综合症”吗？他们开门见山地承认“学习者综合症”并不是一个真正的病症。然后他们指出了我思考过很多次的事情，特别是现在我作为软件工程师工作了太久之后。你会看到人们进来，他们非常兴奋，充满干劲，觉得他们拥有解决一切问题的方案。对吧？或者“如果我们只使用这种技术或那种技术会怎样？”我们之前讨论过各种语言，有些已经有三十年甚至更久的历史了……哦，四十年了，哇，我不敢相信已经是 2017 年了……总之，我们使用 C++，虽然我们使用 C++ 11，快到 14 了，即使那样也有 bug。
But C++ goes back many, many years, has a lot of inertia behind it, a lot of historic stuff. And people are like, oh, if we could just use insert whatever up and coming language now, then all our problems would be solved. Sure, Rust. And what I find myself realizing is that I think one of the desires in technology, or at least for me, and I think for my coworkers, is to always be learning something new
但 C++ 可以追溯到很多年前，背后有很大的惯性，有很多历史包袱。人们会说：“哦，如果我们能使用（插入任何新兴语言），那么我们所有的问题都会迎刃而解。”当然，Rust。我发现自己意识到，我认为技术领域的一种渴望，或者至少对我来说，以及对我的同事来说，总是想学习新东西，
just for the sake of having an excuse to learn it. Like we have pretty flexible jobs for the most part where we have a lot of autonomy relative to, you know, if you were working on a factory assembly line or something. You have a lot of latitude to make decisions on things. And so people look for excuses to use things that they would just like to learn. And this article points out under the context of of sort of web development
仅仅是为了有一个学习它的借口。在很大程度上，我们有相当灵活的工作，相对于你在工厂流水线上工作之类的，我们有很大的自主权。你有很大的余地来做决定。所以人们寻找借口去使用他们想学的东西。这篇文章在 Web 开发的背景下指出了
all the different frameworks that come out and how you have to know this and know that you're expected to know you know all of the full stack front end back end databases you're you know you're kind of expecting everything but then people even just have all this desire to learn new frameworks but the most they ever do is probably you know know, code up an example. They never really do much with it. And so they, they feel like they're accomplishing all of this learning. Um, but it's really doesn't help them. It doesn't benefit anything. They're not saying what problem do I have and could I find something better to solve it with? Uh, and so it's not a terribly long article, but it just begs the question that I think I notice a lot, which is,
所有出现的不同框架，以及你必须知道这个、知道那个，被期望知道全栈、前端、后端、数据库，你被期望什么都懂。但人们甚至只是有这种学习新框架的渴望，但他们最多可能只是写了一个示例。他们从来没有真正用它做过什么。所以他们觉得自己在完成所有的学习，但这真的没有帮助。它没有任何好处。他们并没有问“我有什么问题，我能找到更好的东西来解决它吗？”所以，这不是一篇很长的文章，但它提出了一个我认为我经常注意到的问题，即：
although it's great to learn. And I mean, we have a podcast where we talk about some technology or programming language every month. I think that it is important to, to realize that it's not always great to jump on the newest thing. And that as you're using new things, as opposed to just being like,
虽然学习很好。我的意思是，我们有一个播客，每个月我们都会谈论一些技术或编程语言。我认为重要的是要意识到，盲目追逐最新事物并不总是好事。当你使用新事物时，而不是仅仅表现得像，
Oh, this is the best thing ever. Let's use it everywhere. You know, I always always I use this expression. It's not mine. I don't know where it came from, though. But, you know, it's another tool in the tool belt. Right.
“这是有史以来最好的东西。让我们到处使用它。”你知道，我总是使用这个表达。它不是我的，我不知道它来自哪里。但你知道，这是工具带里的另一个工具。对吧？
If all you have is a hammer, everything's a nail. So don't only have a hammer. You know, get yourself a set of tools and then make sure you use the right tool for the right job. Going around and just saying like oh rust is cool i mean rust is cool but like going around saying rust is cool let's solve all the problems in rust yeah that's not gonna end up any better than when we try to solve all the problems in c++ or try to solve all the problems in java right um although any of those might work they're probably not the best answer yeah i mean i i actually
如果你手里只有一把锤子，看什么都像钉子。所以不要只拥有一把锤子。给自己准备一套工具，然后确保在正确的工作中使用正确的工具。到处说“哦，Rust 很酷”，我的意思是 Rust 是很酷，但到处说“Rust 很酷，让我们用 Rust 解决所有问题”，那并不会比我们尝试用 C++ 或 Java 解决所有问题更好，对吧？虽然其中任何一个都可能奏效，但它们可能不是最好的答案。是的，我的意思是，我其实
experienced this firsthand when i was brand new like first job um out of undergrad i only really knew c++ and uh and a little bit of java and uh basically i i wanted to build this is a sort of side project of mine, which I wanted to build this kind of really kind of open ended environment where I had these agents that had different AI and stuff like that. And, you know, because it was AI and I was having a lot of different variables, I need something that's really dynamic. And so I basically had this class in C++. C++ class, it just had a map from variant to variant. And then I had this variant class that used the boost variant library. So it could be an integer or a string or it could be anything, right? Oh, dear.
亲身经历过这一点，当我刚入行时，大学毕业后的第一份工作，我只真正了解 C++ 和一点点 Java。基本上，我想构建一个我自己的副项目，我想构建一个非常开放的环境，我有这些具有不同 AI 的代理等等。而且，因为它是 AI，而且我有许多不同的变量，我需要一些非常动态的东西。所以我基本上在 C++ 中写了这个类。C++ 类，它只是一个从 variant 到 variant 的映射。然后我有一个使用 boost variant 库的 variant 类。所以它可以是一个整数，或者一个字符串，或者任何东西，对吧？哦，天哪。
And so I had this class that was basically just a map of anything to anything. And then everything just started being a map of anything to anything. And I ended up with this sort of dynamic language. I could even script things like that. And at some point I realized, like not soon after, that I had built like just the worst version of Python ever. You know, like it was just, I mean, it was that Python was exactly that, but then a million other things too and way optimized and stuff like that. And I think the big thing about this show is we explain all these different languages to people
所以我有一个类，基本上只是一个从任何东西到任何东西的映射。然后一切都开始变成从任何东西到任何东西的映射。我最终得到了这种动态语言。我甚至可以编写类似那样的脚本。在某个时刻，我意识到，没过多久，我就构建了一个有史以来最糟糕的 Python 版本。你知道，它就是……我的意思是，Python 正是那样，但还有一百万其他东西，而且优化得更好之类的。我认为这个节目的重点是我们向人们解释所有这些不同的语言，
so that they can sort of understand the context like they can embed the languages that they know in sort of this greater context and so they won't try and build like a very poor man's python in c++ um but yeah with that said i kind of i have uh sort of the opposite problem where I don't really like learning a bunch of different languages to do. Like, I don't like learning some crazy language. I would rather sort of like deconstruct something into a language that already exists. Like, I've worked at jobs where people had sort of custom languages. And it almost always seemed like that language could have been replaced with Python.
这样他们就可以理解背景，他们可以将他们所知道的语言嵌入到这种更大的背景中，这样他们就不会尝试在 C++ 中构建一个非常贫穷的 Python。但话虽如此，我有一种相反的问题，我不喜欢为了做某事而学习一堆不同的语言。我不喜欢学习一些疯狂的语言。我宁愿把东西解构为已经存在的语言。比如，我曾在人们拥有自定义语言的地方工作过。而且几乎总是看起来那种语言可以用 Python 代替。
But I do have times where I have sort of this, maybe it's like an analysis paralysis where I want to do a project and there's maybe four or five different frameworks. And I end up bouncing between learning these frameworks instead of actually doing the project. And if i just picked even the worst of the five i would have got way more done yeah so on the exact topic of the article i think it's saying that is you know maybe a little less learning and a little more using the thing you know to get stuff done uh
但我确实有的时候会有某种分析瘫痪，我想做一个项目，可能有四五个不同的框架。我最终在学习这些框架之间徘徊，而不是真正去做项目。如果我只是随便选了五个中最差的一个，我也会完成得更多。是的，关于文章的主题，我认为它是在说，也许少一点学习，多一点使用你所知道的东西来完成工作。
but yeah i mean i think you're absolutely right which is whenever i start a project and i can choose what to do or how to approach it the going is really slow i find it very difficult to discipline myself to sort of i'm just going to pick something and solve it poorly and then figure out how to do it again um yeah i tend to bounce back and forth oh like he's working on some project that is like wrote a little bit of java then wrote a little bit of python then it's like oh maybe i should do it in c++ i was just like oh this is terrible like i'm just gonna pick one get it done and then i'll choose yeah that's a good point i actually i'm working on a a little game to teach machine learning to uh kids i've
但是的，我认为你是绝对正确的。每当我开始一个项目，我可以选择做什么或如何处理它时，进展真的很慢。我发现很难约束自己，我只是想随便选一个，把它做得很烂，然后再想办法重做。是的，我倾向于来回徘徊。哦，就像他正在做一个项目，写了一点 Java，然后写了一点 Python，然后就像“哦，也许我应该用 C++ 做”。我当时就觉得“哦，这太糟糕了”。我只是要选一个，把它做完，然后再选择。是的，这是一个很好的观点。其实我正在做一个小游戏来教孩子们机器学习，我
been working on this for for years but i i i shelved it for a long time and now i got back into it and uh there's this engine that everybody uses now it just exploded in popularity it's called godot uh like the mathematician and uh it has their own language called Godot script and I just hated having to learn another language so I kind of you know put it off I was looking at other frameworks and things like that and then finally I just said forget it let me just learn this Godot script and and you know get this done because because this I mean if you could learn this language the tooling on this thing's amazing
已经为此工作了多年，但我把它搁置了很长时间，现在我又重新开始了。现在有一个每个人都在使用的引擎，它的人气爆炸式增长，叫 Godot，像那个数学家一样。它有自己的语言叫 Godot script，我只是讨厌不得不学习另一种语言，所以我把它推迟了。我看了其他框架之类的东西，最后我只是说“算了吧，让我学习这个 Godot script，把它做完”。因为如果能学会这门语言，这个东西的工具链太棒了。
and basically it was a bit of a pain for a few days but i think part of you know recording this show for however many years we've been doing it i was able to pick up the language pretty quick in like an hour or so and then uh yeah i actually have a quick like a simple demo like like a level one of the game um um and it exports to android and everything else but it's like if i didn't get over that barrier i just wouldn't have had really anything so it's definitely it's a tricky balance but uh yeah learner syndrome is kind of going too far on the other end so with that in mind my tool this show is unity 3d ml agents so yeah so you know the only engine that really rivals godot is unity um unity's closed source so uh i'm gonna stick with godot
基本上，这几天有点痛苦，但我认为录制这个节目的部分原因，无论我们做了多少年，我能够在大约一小时左右很快学会这门语言。然后，是的，我其实有一个简单的演示，比如游戏的第一关，它还可以导出到 Android 和其他平台。但如果我没有跨过那个障碍，我就真的什么都没有了。所以这绝对是一个微妙的平衡，但“学习者综合症”有点走得太远了。考虑到这一点，我这个节目的工具是 Unity 3D ML Agents。所以，你知道，唯一真正能与 Godot 竞争的引擎是 Unity。Unity 是闭源的，所以我打算坚持使用 Godot
for now but it's pretty amazing i mean at most a lot of professional game studios use unity um it's got a bunch of amazing features i think we actually did we do a show on unity yeah we did okay so so uh check out that show we talk about it in great detail um they added this thing yeah ml agents basically um they add a variety of different reinforcement learning um agents and uh it's pretty cool so so you can you can give them sort of a a you know a representation of the world or you could even just have a camera and it will learn from the camera you know as best they can and yeah they have a bunch of cool demos they have this this multi-age, so they have different sort of categories,
目前为止，但这非常惊人。我的意思是，大多数专业游戏工作室都使用 Unity。它有很多惊人的功能。我想我们其实做过关于 Unity 的节目吗？是的，我们做过。好吧，去看看那个节目，我们非常详细地讨论了它。他们添加了这个东西，ML Agents，基本上他们添加了各种不同的强化学习代理，这非常酷。所以你可以给它们一个世界的表示，或者你甚至可以只放一个摄像头，它会尽可能地从摄像头学习。是的，他们有很多很酷的演示。他们有这种多代理，所以他们有不同的类别，
which I found kind of interesting. They have sort of a single agent. So this is, you know, imagine you're writing AI to play Frogger, like to be the frog in Frogger. So in this case, you know, you have this environment with all these cars that move around and stuff like that. And the agent has to sort of, you know, navigate this environment with all these cars that move around and stuff like that and the agent has to sort of you know navigate that maze right but then it gets much more interesting with multiple agents so you can have for example 10 agents that are all sort of
我觉得这很有趣。他们有单代理。所以，想象一下你正在编写 AI 来玩 Frogger，比如成为 Frogger 中的青蛙。在这种情况下，你有一个环境，里面有所有这些移动的汽车之类的东西。代理必须在所有这些移动的汽车的环境中导航，代理必须在迷宫中导航，对吧？但当有多个代理时，它就变得更有趣了。所以你可以有，例如，10 个代理，它们都是
cooperating they have like one mind that's controlling all 10 of them and so they can kind of coordinate you have this one where they're all sort of them and so they can kind of coordinate um you have this one where they're all sort of 10 agents but they're all against each other and so they don't share information and stuff like that and it kind of breaks it down it has some cool demos and uh i i noticed they left out the case where there's more than three agents or more than two agents that can cooperate um and the reason why they left it out is that's an open research problem so it says actually says demo coming soon for that one and i'm wondering like it's it's sort of like saying you know it's a joke yeah yeah it's sort of like saying space travel you know faster than light travel coming soon yeah
合作的。它们有一个控制所有 10 个代理的头脑，所以它们可以协调。你有一个它们都是 10 个代理，但它们都在互相竞争，所以它们不共享信息之类的。它分解了它，有一些很酷的演示。我注意到他们遗漏了超过三个代理或超过两个代理可以合作的情况。他们遗漏的原因是这是一个开放的研究问题。所以它实际上说“演示即将推出”。我心想，这就像是在说，你知道，这是一个笑话。是的，这就像是在说太空旅行，你知道，超光速旅行即将到来。
yeah like as a reinforcement learning researcher, I'm just like, really? How soon is that? But I mean, they could obviously build something, but something that would work in that general problem is currently like an open research problem. But it's pretty cool. Definitely check it out. The demos look pretty neat. So. definitely check it out and the demos look pretty neat so that's so i think it's now time for book of the book of the show i'm totally cheating here but
是的，作为一个强化学习研究员，我只是想，真的吗？那有多快？但我的意思是，他们显然可以构建一些东西，但在那个一般问题中能起作用的东西目前是一个开放的研究问题。但这非常酷。一定要看一看。演示看起来很不错。所以，一定要看一看，演示看起来很不错。所以，我想现在是节目图书的时间了。我完全是在作弊，但是
i have to admit i've done a ton of reading in this game and uh and uh took my whole month or at least since the last show we recorded it's called 80 days it's based on the Jules Verne book which I have not read because I've been too busy playing this game but it I think it's pretty faithful to the book from reading the reviews and things like that basically in 80 days you there's a very small sort of shell of a game where you have to go to different cities and you can pick which city to go to and you can take a few actions when you're in the city. But that's basically a thin shell around what is really like a very detailed, you know, interactive fiction. So there's a bunch of sort of think of an interactive fiction as like a choose your own adventure um but just a little bit more open-ended
我必须承认，我在这个游戏中读了很多书，这花了我整个月的时间，或者至少是从我们录制的上一期节目以来。它叫《80 天环游地球》（80 Days），它是基于儒勒·凡尔纳的书，我还没读过，因为我太忙于玩这个游戏了。但我认为从阅读评论来看，它对原著非常忠实。基本上在《80 天》中，有一个非常小的游戏外壳，你必须去不同的城市，你可以选择去哪个城市，当你在这个城市时，你可以采取一些行动。但这基本上是一个非常详细的互动小说的薄外壳。所以有很多，把互动小说想象成“选择你自己的冒险”，但稍微更开放一点，
right um and yeah you can depending on what trajectory you take to go around the world and there's many um you get just all these really interesting stories and you know i won't spoil any of it because it's it's like a book you know if you if i was to say one of the stories it would just ruin it so i won't spoil anything but uh um it's really cool i highly recommend it they have it on android ios they probably have it on pc as well um and uh yeah check it out and it's actually it makes me really want to read the actual book so i i had always thought that 80 days was a i knew it was a fiction book but i thought it was a fiction book based on the real world you know like like i figured they'd be taking boats and trains and stuff like that
对吧？是的，根据你环游世界所采取的轨迹，有很多种，你会得到所有这些非常有趣的故事。我不会剧透任何内容，因为它就像一本书，如果我说出其中一个故事，它就会毁了它。所以我不会剧透任何东西，但它真的很酷，我强烈推荐它。他们在 Android、iOS 上都有，他们可能在 PC 上也有。去看看吧，它真的让我很想读原著。我一直以为《80 天》是一本小说，我知道它是一本小说，但我以为它是一本基于现实世界的小说，你知道，就像我想象他们会坐船和火车之类的。
what i did not expect was there's a bunch of like fantastical creatures and things like that um and uh uh you know a bunch of like fantastical machines and everything it's it's really cool and and it's very well done very nice my book of the show is a traditional book uh although i did listen to it instead of read it is forging forging hefestus um so this book i think is relatively new and i didn't find it to be an especially uh deep or in engaging book but it was a nice sort of whatever you call like uh pop pop breed like pop music popular whatever i don't know um and it is a science fiction book i guess it's about a a woman who has superpowers oh this is gonna sound so cheesy anyways it's about a woman who has superpowers
我没预料到的是，里面有一堆奇幻生物之类的东西，还有一堆奇幻机器，它真的很酷，而且做得非常好。非常棒。我这个节目的书是一本传统的书，虽然我是听的而不是读的，叫《锻造赫菲斯托斯》（Forging Hephaestus）。这本书我认为相对较新，我并没有觉得它是一本特别深刻或引人入胜的书，但它是一种不错的，随便你怎么称呼，比如流行读物，流行音乐，随便吧，我不知道。它是一本科幻小说，我想它是关于一个拥有超能力的女人。哦，这听起来太俗气了。总之，它是关于一个拥有超能力的女人，
also likes building things and she gets herself wrapped up into a world where lots of other people have superpowers and she basically is in finds herself in league with a group of villains and sort of talking through how the villains interact and, you know, how the world works with all the superheroes. And it doesn't go in depth to, you know, trying to come up with plausible science as to how all this works. In fact, it sort of pokes fun at that. But it's just a sort of a nice fun light read um and this was by a person named drew hayes i've i've never read anything of theirs before but i thought this was a nice easy read definitely didn't you know wasn't a brain burner or like whoa i gotta rewind that hang on what just happened uh just a nice easy light fun read about
也喜欢制造东西，她把自己卷入了一个很多人都有超能力的世界。她基本上发现自己与一群恶棍结盟，并讨论恶棍们是如何互动的，以及世界是如何与所有超级英雄一起运作的。它没有深入探讨试图想出关于这一切如何运作的合理科学。事实上，它甚至以此为乐。但这只是一个不错的、有趣的、轻松的读物。这是由一个叫 Drew Hayes 的人写的，我以前从未读过他们的任何东西，但我认为这是一个不错的、轻松的读物，绝对不是那种烧脑的，或者那种“哇，我得倒回去，等等，刚才发生了什么”的书，只是一个关于
sort of you know what i imagine you know, what I imagine, you know, well, they actually do write books about comic books, like books involving the people from comic books. It's kind of like that. Like if you just have a nice, like what you would read in a comic book, but someone actually wrote it with words instead of, uh, comic book pages. Cool. I'm doing a terrible job. It's so hard to describe a book no it sounds good i mean it sounds like uh is it like a kind of a parody of of comic books or no it's just in that vein so i've previously brandon sanderson has uh a book about superheroes as well um what was it called oh man i think it's like calamity and there's i think i've recommended a
你知道，我所想象的，你知道，好吧，他们确实写关于漫画书的书，比如涉及漫画书人物的书。它有点像那样。就像如果你只是有一个不错的，就像你在漫画书里读到的东西，但有人实际上用文字而不是漫画书页面写了出来。酷。我做得太糟糕了。描述一本书太难了。不，听起来不错。我的意思是，它听起来像是一种对漫画书的模仿吗？不，它只是那个风格的。所以我之前 Brandon Sanderson 也有关于超级英雄的书，叫什么来着？哦，天哪，我想是《Calamity》，我想我推荐过那个系列中的
couple of the books in that series uh anyways and this is sort of in a similar vein except a little more goofy and light-hearted i guess um but no it's not a parody of it it's just sort of you know most you can't write a comic book about batman you know because batman is licensed so everyone has to come up with their own kind of stuff and they're not you know making fun of batman they didn't have their own characters and doing their own thing but i you can't sort of write in that without paying some sort of homage to those kinds of things so i wouldn't say it's a parody but it is just trying to be sort of in the same style. Okay, that makes sense. Very cool.
几本书。总之，这有点类似，只是稍微有点傻气和轻松。但它不是模仿，它只是，你知道，大多数人不能写关于蝙蝠侠的漫画书，因为蝙蝠侠是有版权的。所以每个人都必须想出自己的东西，他们不是在取笑蝙蝠侠，他们有自己的角色，做自己的事情。但你不能在不向那种东西致敬的情况下写那种东西。所以我不会说它是模仿，但它确实是在尝试以同样的风格创作。好吧，这说得通。非常酷。
I feel like I should just read the, whatever, the back of the book because I think they would do a better job. That's boring. You can just go online and do that. Yeah, yeah. I mean, the goal is to get people inspired enough to do that. So, yes, if you're looking for a lighthearted book set in a comic book style setting
我觉得我应该直接读一下书的背面，因为我觉得他们会做得更好。那很无聊。你可以直接上网做那个。是的，是的。我的意思是，目标是激励人们去做这件事。所以，是的，如果你正在寻找一本以漫画书风格设置的轻松书籍，
without any trademark infringing characters i would recommend forging hefestus uh it's the villain's code book one although as far as i know there's no book two yet so tbd if it actually becomes a series very cool yeah i'm reading uh the book of the show from last month uh the claude shannon book when i'm done with that i'm actually and i'm actually um i chose to read that book like like read read it um so i have a really long flight coming up so i think i will i will get this and i'll listen to it nice cool and i'll listen to it on audible so I have uh I have an audible subscription and it's been uh the audience knows probably better than we do or someone in the audience knows when I said I
没有任何侵犯商标的角色，我会推荐《锻造赫菲斯托斯》。它是《恶棍守则》（Villain's Code）的第一本书，虽然据我所知还没有第二本书，所以是否会成为一个系列还有待观察。非常酷。是的，我正在读上个月节目推荐的书，那本克劳德·香农（Claude Shannon）的书。当我读完那本时，我其实……我选择读那本书，就像“读”它。所以我即将有一段很长的飞行，我想我会买这个，我会听它。不错，酷。我会用 Audible 听它。所以我有一个 Audible 订阅，而且它已经……听众可能比我们更清楚，或者听众中的某个人知道当我说我
got the subscription I think it's been about six months but I've definitely used every credit almost immediately and it's been it's been a lot of fun if you want to get an audible subscription and help us out at the same time, you can go to audibletrial.com programmingthrowdown. We have a link in the show notes. And when you sign up, you'll get a free book and you'll also help out the show.
买了订阅时，我想已经大约六个月了，但我绝对几乎立即用完了每一个积分，这很有趣。如果你想获得 Audible 订阅并同时帮助我们，你可以去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。我们在节目说明中有一个链接。当你注册时，你会得到一本书，你也会帮助这个节目。
Very nice. And Jason already mentioned our Patreon, but if you go to patreon.com programmingthrowdown, you can elect to give us a donation for each episode that we release and we're thankful to all the people who have done audible trials uh and who sponsor us on patreon uh definitely helps encourage us uh to keep making shows yeah definitely i mean you can uh i won't i won't feel bad if uh i won't make you feel bad if you join Patreon
非常好。Jason 已经提到了我们的 Patreon，但如果你去 patreon.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以选择为我们发布的每一集节目捐款。我们感谢所有进行过 Audible 试用的人，以及在 Patreon 上赞助我们的人。这绝对有助于鼓励我们继续制作节目。是的，绝对的。我的意思是，你可以……我不会让你因为加入 Patreon 而感到难过。
win the biggest prize and then leave you're totally free to do that but we appreciate everybody even if you just joined for a month we appreciate that you helped us out, it really keeps the show going it lets us reach new people
赢得最大的奖品然后离开，你完全可以这样做。但我们感谢每一个人，即使你只是加入了一个月，我们也感谢你帮助了我们。它真的让节目得以继续，让我们接触到新的人，
and all that good stuff my tool of the show is firefox developer edition so uh one thing about this so firefox alpha which hopefully becomes beta or becomes firefox very soon is amazing um and and actually i uh haven't used firefox hadn't used firefox in years. Somebody at work just said, hey, you have to check out the new Firefox. It was somebody who works on our WebSpeed team. And so I took his opinion really seriously.
以及所有那些好东西。我这个节目的工具是 Firefox 开发者版。所以，关于这个的一件事，Firefox Alpha，希望它很快成为 Beta 或成为 Firefox，非常惊人。而且其实我……我多年没用过 Firefox 了。工作中的某个人只是说：“嘿，你必须看看新的 Firefox。”那是我们 WebSpeed 团队的人。所以我非常认真地对待他的意见。
And so I checked it out. And it is amazing. Like, I can't wait for this to come out. It doesn't use very much RAM. It runs super fast. And I feel like Chrome was really amazing when Chrome came out. But now it's kind of, especially in terms of how much memory it uses, it's becoming kind of more and more bloated. And Firefox, they basically redid everything.
所以我看了看。它太惊人了。就像，我迫不及待地想让它发布。它占用的内存不多。它运行速度超快。我觉得 Chrome 在刚出来时真的很棒。但现在它有点，特别是在内存占用方面，变得越来越臃肿。而 Firefox，他们基本上重做了所有东西。
They started kind of from the ground up. And I think a lot of it is in rust that they rewrote it in rust i don't know if that matters or not in terms of like what i'm seeing but i'm just the performance is unbelievable um and so firefox developer edition is a fork of firefox alpha which has a bunch of really cool features for developers. Like it'll do really intense profiling of your website. It has a bunch of really cool features like JavaScript debugging and things like that. And it's running Firefox Alpha. And even though it has all these developer features, you could use it as your regular browser if you wanted to.
他们从头开始。而且我认为其中很多是用 Rust 编写的，他们用 Rust 重写了它。我不知道这对我所看到的东西是否有影响，但我只是觉得性能令人难以置信。所以 Firefox 开发者版是 Firefox Alpha 的一个分支，它为开发者提供了一堆非常酷的功能。比如它会对你的网站进行非常深入的分析。它有一堆非常酷的功能，比如 JavaScript 调试之类的。而且它运行的是 Firefox Alpha。即使它有所有这些开发者功能，如果你愿意，你也可以把它当作你的常规浏览器使用。
So definitely download this. Check it out. You'll be blown away at how amazing it is um and and you could also see some really cool debugging while you're there i saw someone else mentioned that the new firefox was pretty good but i haven't i don't know i'm too lazy now i guess i should check it out but will it migrate all of my like bookmarks and tabs because i have lots of tabs yeah so um you know i actually had back when i ran firefox and chrome kind of alternating um there's a thing called a bookmark box it's an extension and it basically syncs your bookmarks to dropbox and if you run the same extension on on multiple browsers it'll just keep everything in sync oh i should have done i should make that the tool of
所以一定要下载这个。去看看吧。你会惊讶于它有多棒，嗯，而且你在那里的时候还可以看到一些非常酷的调试功能。我看到有人提到新版火狐浏览器相当不错，但我不知道，我现在太懒了，我想我应该去看看，但它会迁移我所有的书签和标签页吗？因为我有很多标签页。是的，嗯，你知道，其实以前我运行火狐和谷歌浏览器时是交替使用的，有一个叫“书签盒子”（Bookmark Box）的东西，它是一个扩展程序，基本上可以把你的书签同步到 Dropbox，如果你在多个浏览器上运行同一个扩展程序，它就会保持一切同步。哦，我应该早点做，我应该把它作为本期节目的工具，现在就安装它。嗯，给你，你可以那样做。是的，我不知道，我想我的情况是我用了大量的标签页，我把标签页当作一种临时的书签之类的东西，如果我的浏览器崩溃了，我丢失了它们，我会很难过。但是，嗯，我只是觉得，创建一个书签似乎太永久了。嗯，
the show and install it right now um there you go you could do that yeah i don't know i i guess my thing is i use tons of tabs like i use tabs as sort of a light for an ephemeral bookmark or whatever um which makes me sad if my browser ever crashes and I lose my, but, um, I just sort of, I don't like the creating a bookmark seems so permanent. Um,
是的，确实如此。真的需要一个更好的方式。我喜欢滚动浏览 Hacker News 或 Reddit 之类的网站，然后只需按住 Command 键点击或用鼠标中键点击，就像这样，点、点、
yeah, it's true. There really needs to be a better, and I like just sort of scrolling through hacker news or Reddit or whatever, and just like, you know, doing command click or middle click on the mouse and just like click, click,
点、点、点、点、点，打开一大堆东西，把它们留着，你知道，我稍后再浏览，然后关闭。我不想把它们加入书签，但天哪，在工作中，当人们走过来看到我的屏幕时，我总是受到批评，他们会说：“伙计，你开了多少个标签页啊？”你知道，这很有趣，我也遇到过完全一样的情况，每个人也对我这么说。这就像是“英雄所见略同”，我打算这么说，下次有人再跟我说的时候，我就说伟大的杰森
click, click, click, click click click like opening a ton of things and leaving them as sort of like a very you know i'll skim them later and then close i don't want to bookmark it but man i get so much flack at work when people ever come by and they're like dude how many tabs do you have you know it's funny i get i have exactly the same thing and everyone says the same thing to me too it's like great minds think alike i'm gonna go with that i'm gonna say next time someone tells me that the great jason
说他也开了大量的标签页，我会做同样的事情，没人会知道另一个人是谁。哦，这就对了。我们现在只需要像著名的推特账号之类的东西，然后说：“没错，帕特里克说的。”我们需要获得蓝色徽章之类的东西，那个认证徽章。我用推特已经不知道多久了，我听说它最近很流行。
said that he also runs a ton of tabs and i'll do the same thing and no one will know that no one will know who the other one is oh there we go uh we just need like famous twitter accounts now or something be like yeah that's right. Patrick says. We need to get the blue badge or whatever. The verified badge. I've been on Twitter and I don't even know how long. I hear it's popular these days.
我觉得我得发表一份财务声明。我做空了推特。如果它倒闭了，我就能赚钱。等等，你是开玩笑还是认真的？不，我是认真的，但这没关系。真的吗？是的，其实我这辈子从来没做空过任何东西。我的意思是，我知道那是什么，但我只是觉得那是专业人士干的事。哦，哇，我感到害怕，或者我不知道，你知道，我不是那种适合咨询投资建议的人。好吧，这会让谈话严重偏离主题，但是的，是的，
I feel like I have to give a financial statement. I'm short Twitter. If it goes down, that makes me money. Wait, are you kidding or are you serious no i'm serious but that's okay really yeah i've actually i've never shorted anything my whole life i mean i know what it is but i just i just feel like it's for it's for the pros oh wow i i feel scared or i don't know i'm not you know i'm not a good person to ask investment advice okay well this will be it'll derail the conversation greatly but yes i yeah yeah
所以我们要继续了。有趣，好吧，我没有做多推特，所以如果他们倒闭了，我也不会感到遗憾。嗯，给你，我本期的工具是一个游戏，惊喜，是《见证者》（The Witness）。是的，我知道我参加得太晚了，每个人很久以前就在他们的电脑上玩过这个游戏了，但我一直在我的 iPad 上玩它。虽然我确实是在没有手柄的情况下开始玩的，我确实有一个无线手柄，起初我试图玩这个游戏，我看到一些评论说“哦，你真的必须使用手柄”，我当时想“哦，这没问题”，我只是享受点击的感觉，这运行得很好。然后我玩到了几个谜题，我就想“哦，你完全必须得有一个手柄”。哦，所以，如果你玩过《见证者》，你就会
so we'll move on interesting okay i'm not long twitter so no no spilt milk if uh they go down um there you go my tool of the show is a game surprise uh the witness and yes i know i'm really late to the party everyone already played this a long time ago on their computer um but i've been playing it on my ipad and uh although i did start playing it without a controller like i do have a wireless controller and i initially i was trying to play this and i saw some of the reviews saying oh you really got to use a controller i was like oh this is no problem um i'm just enjoying just tapping this is working well and then i got to a couple puzzles and i was like oh you totally have to have a controller um oh and so do well if you've have you if you've played the witness you'll you'll
知道，但如果你没玩过，这是一款解谜游戏，我想是制作《时空幻境》（Braid）的那个人做的，乔纳森·布洛（Jonathan Blow），是吗？是的，没错。所以它有点像《神秘岛》（Myst）那种风格，如果你玩过的话，那里有各种各样的谜题要做，但有时谜题非常明显，比如屏幕上有一个闪烁的东西，你需要以某种方式与它互动。有时你需要非常小心地在环境中定位自己，比如朝一个非常特定的方向看，从一个非常特定的位置看，这样你才能看到线索。所以如果你想象一下，就像他们在
know but if you've not it's a puzzle game by this i think it's the same guy who made um braid jonathan blow is it yeah that's right and so it's uh in the vein of kind of like i guess mr raven if you've ever played played one of those where um there's all of these puzzles to do but sometimes the puzzles are you know very obvious like there's a blinking thing on the screen and you need to you know interact with it in some way and sometimes you need to sort of position yourself very carefully within the environment like look in a very specific direction uh from a very specific spot so that you can see a clue um so if you imagine like whatever they show when
巨石阵展示的那样，在特定的夜晚，如果你看向特定石头上钻出的特定孔洞，那么你就能看到月亮出现在那个孔洞里，或者类似的事情。你知道，类似那样，你需要排在那个特定的位置。对于微调，对我来说，需要视频游戏手柄，那种无线手柄，才能稍微移动一下你的位置。但除此之外，游戏本身我真的很喜欢。我玩得很烂，我觉得这就像那种让你觉得错过了很多东西的游戏，但我一直试图不作弊，不使用攻略指南。好吧，这不是作弊，但我只是觉得这是那种让你觉得错过了很多东西的游戏，但
they you know do stonehenge like on a certain night if you look to a certain hole drilled in a certain stone then you can see the you know for one minute the moon appears in the hole or whatever you know something like that like you need to be lined up at this specific spot and if the fine-tune adjustments sort of necessitate needing a for me uh the video game controller the sort of wireless controller to be able to kind of move your position very slightly but other than that the game itself i'm really enjoying i'm terrible at it i think like i feel it's one of those things that makes you feel like you're missing out a bunch of things but i've been trying to not cheat and use the strategy guide okay it's not cheating but i just feel is one of those things that makes you feel like you're missing out a bunch of things but
我一直试图不作弊，不使用攻略指南。好吧，这不是作弊，但我只是尽量不使用攻略指南，因为我知道我可以查到所有谜题的答案，但如果我要那样做，我还不如直接在 YouTube 上看通关视频之类的。是的，不要毁了游戏。是的，完全正确。嗯，但要通关确实很难，有些东西我确实不得不看几次攻略指南，因为有些东西我觉得，哦，那并不是完全显而易见的。而且我是一个注意力不集中的玩家。
i've been trying to not cheat and use the strategy guide okay it's not cheating but i just try not to use the strategy guide because i know i could just look up all the answers to all the puzzles but if i'm going to do that i should just you know like watch a walkthrough on youtube or something yeah i don't ruin the game yeah exactly um but it's really tough to you know sort of play through and some of the things, I have had to look at the strategy guide a couple of times because some stuff I felt like, oh, that wasn't completely obvious. And I am a not long attention span gamer.
所以我知道在弄明白之前我就会放弃。但总的来说，我真的很喜欢这些谜题。它们非常多样化。而且，我的意思是，我认为它们考虑得非常周全。所以如果你之前没有看过《见证者》，如果你是解谜游戏玩家，现在它可以在我想是 PC、安卓、iOS 上玩，你知道，所有平台都有。而且它是一款稍微有点昂贵的游戏，我想我买的时候大概是 15 或 20 美元。但我的意思是，这是一款非常好的游戏，你在
So I knew I would just give up before figuring it out. But overall, I've really enjoyed the puzzles. They're very varied. And I mean, I think they're pretty well thought out. So if you've not checked out The witness before a puzzle gamer puzzle game uh now it's available on i think pc android ios you know everything so and it is a little bit of a premium game i think it i think when i bought it was like 15 or 20 dollars um but i mean it's a really good game and you would pay way more than that you know for it on
PC 上刚出来的时候会花更多的钱买它，所以我不觉得那么糟糕。是的，这很有道理。其实我很惊讶 iOS 上没有 50 款这样的游戏。是的，我的意思是，是的，看起来，我的意思是，我很惊讶我仍然觉得 50、60、70 美元的游戏真的很贵。事实上，好吧，也许那是真的，也许我不认为我曾经……哦，是的，我只是喜欢……是的，我想我很惊讶 PC 游戏不是 30 美元，我很惊讶 iOS 游戏不是 30 美元。是的，我更同意这种观点。是的，我可能不是那种人，我想我玩过游戏刚出来的时候，但我不在网上玩很多游戏，所以我不会觉得有必要在游戏刚出来时就买它，所以我总是等它们降价到比如 5 美元的时候再买。是的，就像五年后。
the pc when it first came out so i don't feel that bad yeah it makes sense i'm surprised actually that there aren't 50 games on ios yeah i mean yeah it seems like i mean i'm surprised i still feel that 50 60 70 games are really expensive i in fact okay maybe that's true maybe i don't think i've ever oh yeah i just like yeah i guess i'm surprised pc games aren't 30 dollars i'm surprised ios games aren't 30 yes i agree more with this sentiment yeah i'm not the kind of person maybe i think i've played games when they first came out but i don't play a lot online so i don't feel compelled to buy a game when it first comes out so i always buy them when they're yeah like five dollars yeah so yeah like five years later
嘿，这没什么错。很多游戏都是……我仍然玩很多经典游戏。哦，我会说如果你喜欢那种东西，我加入了一个子版块（subreddit）。我想它叫“耐心玩家”（patient gamers），是为那些志同道合的人准备的，关于在游戏发布很久之后才玩它们。这很有趣。因为这都是关于人们说，我知道我已经，
hey nothing wrong with that a lot of games are i still play a lot of classics oh which i will say if you're into that kind of thing i joined a subreddit. I think it's called patient gamers, which is for other people of like-minded thing about playing, playing games long after they've come out. And it's all, it's kind of fun. Cause it's all about people being like, I know that I've,
我终于有时间玩这个游戏了。比如这里有一个热门帖子。目前终于通关了第一部《刺客信条》，谁知道那是多久以前出的。第一次玩《塞尔达传说：众神的三角力量》。哦，天哪，那游戏太棒了。是的，所以人们只是在谈论，而不是谈论哦，最新、最伟大的游戏，
I finally got around to playing this game. Like here's a top post. Currently finally finished the first assassin's creed, which even knows how long that came out. Playing Zelda A Link to the Past for the first time. Oh, man, that game's great. Yeah, so people are just sort of talking about, instead of, oh, the latest, greatest game,
最新、最伟大的补丁，他们谈论的是很久以前出的东西。这里面有很多我忘记了或者不知道的好东西，而且真的很便宜，在打折。而且，我的电脑配置也不足以玩现代游戏。所以就是这样。
the latest, greatest patch, they're talking about things that came out a long time ago. And there's a lot of good stuff in here I sort of forgot about or didn't know about that's really cheap and sales. And also, my computer is not sort of up to scratch to playing modern games. So there's that.
现在，它没有像……它主要不是关于主机游戏的。偶尔会有，但它不像你在模拟器论坛上看到的那样，人们一直在谈论经典的超级任天堂游戏。它更多是关于 PC 游戏的，但你偶尔也会在上面看到主机游戏。不，非常酷。不，我想这是一个混合体，也许是均匀的混合。那是题外话，抱歉。不，不，没关系。是的，我得去看看。我喜欢回去玩老游戏。好了，现在是国际化（Internationalization），也就是他们所说的 i18n。
Now, it doesn't have things like, it isn't mostly about console games. There are occasionally, but it's not like you would see on kind of an emulator or forum where people are talking about talking about you know classic super nintendo games all the time it's a lot about pc games but you will occasionally see um console games on there as well no very cool no i guess it's a mix maybe an even mix uh that was off topic sorry no no it's fine yeah i'll have to check that out i love going back and playing old games all right time for internationalization internationalist i18n as they
我很久都不知道那是什么意思，我不会撒谎。我也是，我完全不知道。所以对于不知道的人来说，i18n 只是因为在“internationalization”的首字母和末字母之间有 18 个字母。所以它只是 internationalization 的 I，然后是 18，然后是 N。本地化（localization）也有同样的缩写，是 L-10-N。是的，很长一段时间里，我都在想，那是什么……我的意思是，我模糊地知道它是关于什么的，但我完全不知道那个背景。我觉得你和我可能是在同一个地方学到这个的。是的，是的，完全正确。所以是的，我也……我不知怎么地通过上下文弄明白了它是什么。但是的，有人必须向我解释它。哦，真的吗？哦，不，我从来没有……总之，我其实只是以为它是像因为如果你说 I-18N，它听起来有点像。
say i did not know what that meant for a very long time i will not lie me too i had no idea so for people who don't know i18n it's it's just because there's 18 letters in between the first and last letter of internationalization. So it's just the I of internationalization, then 18, then the N. And they have the same for localization. It's L-10-N. And yeah, for the longest time, I was like, what is, I mean, I knew vaguely what it was about, but I had no idea the context of that. I feel like you and I probably learned this at the same place yeah yeah exactly so yeah i i too i i somehow by context figured out what it was um but yeah someone had to explain it to me oh really oh no i never yeah anyways i actually just thought it was like because if if you say I-18N, it kind of sounds like it.
所以我从来没有费心去数字母。哦，不。在我的情况下，基本上，我只是去参加了这个会议，一上来，那个人就问：“这里有多少人听说过 I-18N？”然后他们就解释了。哦，好的。好的。是的，我没有……没有那个。所以，所以不同。
So I never bothered to count the letters. Oh, no. In my case, basically, like I just went to this meeting and right off the bat, the person was like, how many people here have heard of I-18N? And they just explained it. Oh, OK. OK. Yeah, I didn't didn't have that. So so different.
让我们谈谈本地化和国际化是什么，以及它们的区别。所以我想，至少对我来说，我大多听到的是国际化（internationalization，I18N）这个词，但人们通常指的是本地化。所以我们先谈谈本地化，因为我认为当你听到这个词时，你可能会想到它。本地化是将计算机应用程序、程序或网站翻译到不同的地区。
Let's talk about what localization and internationalization are and what the difference is. So I think when, for me at least, I mostly hear the term internationalization, I18N, but often people mean localization. So we'll talk about localization first because I think it's the one that, you know, you probably think about when you hear it, which localization is sort of translating a computer app or program or website to a different location.
所以你让它适应个人的语言、习俗，你正在做所有的事情，让它感觉好像那个软件只是为那个地区的人编写的。所以每个人都得到一个不同的区域设置。你知道，当你安装 Windows 时，它会问你，你知道，你在哪里，你说什么语言。其想法是他们想让 Windows 感觉像是支持你所在的世界，就像当地人编写的一样。国际化是制作可以被本地化的软件。所以不在代码中对我们要谈论的内容做假设。但支持本地化的行为被称为国际化。
So you're making it local to a person's language, to their customs for things um you're doing all of the stuff to make it feel as if sort of that piece of software was written for only for people in that area so each person gets a different locale you know if when you install windows and it asks you you know sort of where you are and what language you speak the idea is they want to make it feel like Windows was written supporting where you are in the world as if local people wrote it. Internationalization is making software that can be localized. So not making assumptions in the code about which stuff we're going to talk about. But sort of the act of supporting localization is kind of called internationalization.
但国际化也可能意味着以一种方式做事，使得，你知道，大多数人觉得这是正确的方式，即使你不做本地化。所以你可以在没有本地化的情况下做国际化。我想理论上，你可以在没有国际化的情况下做本地化，但那会非常痛苦。嗯，那会怎么运作？所以我的意思是，你可以，例如，获取程序的所有字节码，并将字符串从英语改为西班牙语，并希望，你知道，它们的长度都一样之类的。
But internationalization could also kind of mean doing things in a way such that, you know, the most people feel that it's kind of the right way, even if you don't do localization. So you can do internationalization without localization. And I guess in theory, you could do localization even if you didn can do internationalization without localization and i guess in theory you could do localization even if you didn't do internationalization but it would make it really miserable um yeah how would that work so i mean you could just for instance like take all of the byte code for a program and change the strings from english to Spanish and hope that, you know, they're all the same length or something.
对。你可以这样做。是的。我不知道人们是否真的那样做。那只会……是的，那会很可怕。对。
Right. You could do it. Yeah. I don't know that people do do that. It would just, yeah, it would be horrible. Right.
你知道，或者，你认为就像你，运行谷歌翻译的等价物，你知道，而不是让别人为你翻译页面，或者你自己做，你可以把页面上的所有文本抓取下来，通过谷歌翻译运行，然后声称那是你的本地化策略，而没有做太多的国际化。
You know, or, or you kind of think of like you, the equivalent of running Google translate, you know, instead of having someone translate your page for you, uh, or, or doing it yourself, you could sort of just scrape all the text off of a page and run it through Google Translate and then claim that was your localization strategy without having done much internationalization.
有道理。好的。总之。那么你为什么不告诉我们一些你应该担心的事情呢？是的，所以本地化和国际化其实真的非常非常难。我的意思是，听起来很容易，但……但有很多复杂性，而且这很有道理。我的意思是，世界是一个很大的地方。是的，有很多……我试图弄清楚，我觉得如果你说错了，效果会很糟糕，所以我很想非常小心。但基本上，有很多文明已经存在了很长时间，所以有一个完全
Makes sense. Okay. Anyways. So why don't you tell us some about the the kinds of things you should worry about yeah so so localization and internationalization is actually really really hard i mean it sounds easy but um but there's a lot of complexity and it makes sense i mean the world it's a big place yeah there's just there's just i try to figure out i feel like if you say this wrong it comes off really bad so i'm like i want to be really careful but basically like there's just several there's many civilizations that have been around for a really long time and so there's a completely
不同的习俗集合，所有这些都反映在语言中，对吧？嗯，例如，有一些语言是从右到左书写的，比如我想希伯来语是从右到左的，而且……我不知道，这是我唯一能想到的。但……而且有些是从下到上书写的，比如我想是日语还是中文之类的，或者也许只是在他们的符号里。但确实有一些语言，当书写时，它们从底部开始向上书写。所以这是需要考虑的事情。比如，如果你在英语中左对齐，在希伯来语中它可能应该右对齐，对吧？有时……世界上有些地方使用句点来分隔数字，所以如果你有一千，它会是 1.000，对吧？我想大多数欧洲国家是这样的。在美国和加拿大，
different set of customs and all of that is sort of reflected in the language right um so for example there are some uh there's some uh languages that go right to left like i think hebrew goes right to left and uh i don't know it's the only one i can think of but uh and there are some that go bottom to top like i think japanese right or chinese or something or maybe it's just in their sign but there are definitely some languages where when written they they start at the bottom and go up um so that's that's something to think about like you so if you have something left justified in in english it probably should be right justified in hebrew right um there's sometimes uh there's some uh places in the world where they use the period to separate numbers so if you have like a thousand it'll be 1.000 right i think most european countries are like this in the u.s and canada
是逗号，对吧？货币符号，对吧？我的意思是，这太容易了，你放一个美元符号，你知道，一百美元，但它是英镑，谁知道有多少种，可能有几十种不同的货币符号，至少。还有日期，我们用月/日/年。实际上，世界上有很多地方用日/月/年，这实际上从计算机科学的角度来看更有意义。但……你知道，那是两种不同的标准。即使像日/月/年可能在逻辑上更有意义，你知道，美国每个人都习惯看到月/日/年。
these commas right currency symbols right i mean so easy you put a dollar sign you know for a hundred dollars but it's a pound and it's who knows how many is probably tens of of different currency symbols at least um also the dates um we do month day year um actually there's like a bunch of places in the world where they do day month year which actually kind of makes more sense like as from a computer science standpoint but uh, you know, those are two sort of different standards. And even though like day, month, year might make sense, you know, logically, you know, everyone in the US is used to seeing month, day, year.
所以我们必须能够适应这两种标准，对吧？所以发生的事情远不止替换字符串。我认为其他事情，你知道，考虑到这一点，很多都适用，我想，也许更多地适用于网站而不是软件本身。但你必须意识到也有文化差异。在你的非食品相关网站的首页上放一个培根芝士汉堡，可能作为美国人对你有吸引力，但对于不吃猪肉的人，他们会看到培根，或者对于不吃牛肉的人，他们会看到汉堡，你知道，他们不会有你想要的反应，或者你认为
And so we have to be able to accommodate sort of both of those standards, right? So there's a lot more going on than just replacing strings. I think other things that, you know, sort of thinking about this, and a lot of it applies, I guess, maybe more so to kind of websites than to software per se. But you got to realize there's cultural differences as well. putting a bacon cheeseburger on the front of your, you know, non food related site, um, may appeal to you as a, you know, American, but somebody who is sort of doesn't eat pork, then they're going to see that bacon or someone who doesn't eat beef is going to see the hamburger, you know, they're going to be, they're not going to have the reaction you wanted them to have, um, or that you thought
他们可能会通过看那个东西而有反应，或者是一个素食主义者，对吧？每个人都会根据不仅仅是你住在哪里，还有关于你是谁的很多不同事情而有不同的反应。所以考虑这些事情，我认为，也可以在这里发挥作用，那就是了解你的受众是谁。是的，是的，绝对。是的。那是一个非常好的观点。我的意思是，即使你做对了所有这些，也不一定是终点。就像你还必须
they might have by looking at that thing or someone who's vegan, right? Like everyone's going to have a different reaction based not just on where you live, but, you know, lots of different things about who you are. And so thinking about those kinds of things, I think, can also come into play here, which is understanding who your audience is. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Yeah. That's a really good point. I mean, it's, even if you do all of this, right, it's not necessarily the end. Like you also have
考虑整个体验和整个应用程序的用户体验，你知道，它是否迎合了你在其中运营的不同市场？我总是想到的一个，我想，是……我没有花大量时间去做，但我知道这是一回事，我总是来自 C 语言，其中一个字符是一个字节，一个 char。一个字符是 8 位，其中只有 127 个是实际有效的。所以它是较低的 127 个数字，你可以查阅，你知道，那个可能赚了数百万美元的家伙，当你搜索 ASCII 表时，它就会出现。是的，没错。而且我忘记了，我想我见过一次这个人。总之，这个人经营着这个网站 asciitable.com，每次你搜索 ASCII 表，如果你是一个 C 程序员，你都
to think about just the entire experience and the whole, the whole app user experience, you know, is it catering to the different markets that you're operating in? The one that I always think about, I guess, is, and I've not spent a ton of time doing it, but I know it's a thing, is I always came from C where a character is a byte, a char. And a character is eight bits of which only 127 are actually valid um and so it's the lower 127 numbers and you can look up you know whatever that guy who's probably made millions of dollars when you search ascii table uh and it comes up yeah that's right and i i forget i think i saw it one time this guy anyways this person runs this website asciitable.com and every time you search asciitable if you're a c programmer you've you've
查阅过这个，我知道你查过。所以这就是我想到字符集时总是想到的。但这绝不是所有字符的开始，对吧？是的，我的意思是，有……所以 Unicode 是……是非常复杂的，我只知道最基础的。但基本上，Unicode 在这一点上已经相当标准化了。它可以表示这么多不同的字符。有令人难以置信的，各种各样的，比如西里尔字母、阿拉伯语、中文，以及不同的繁体和简体，它只是不断地继续下去。但真正酷的是……有不同的，你知道，UTF，Unicode 文本格式。但最有趣、最广泛使用的是 UTF-8。UTF-8 的酷之处在于，你知道，如果你只是处理字符 0
looked this up before i know you have um and so this is what i always think about when i think about character sets but this is by no means not even the beginning of all of the characters that's right yeah i mean there's um so unicorn unicode is uh is incredibly complex i only know just the very basics um but basically unicode is is at this point it's like pretty well standardized um and it can represent just so many different characters um there's unbelievable like all sorts like acrylic and arabic and chinese and different like traditional and simplified and it just like goes on and on and on um but the really kind of cool uh there's different you know utf un Unicode text formats. But the most interesting widely used one is UTF-8. And the cool thing about UTF-8 is, you know, if you're just doing characters 0
到 128，所以，你知道，这包括所有的，你知道，英文字母、数字和符号，以及你知道大多数你习惯在控制台上打印的东西，那些实际上它们转换……它们是相同的字符。换句话说，如果你想打印一个小写 p，那么无论 ASCII 值是多少，UTF-8 值也是一样的。所以你拥有的每个 ASCII 文件也是一个 UTF-8 文件，对吧？所以他们处理这个问题的方式是，你知道，你有你的 0 到 128。所以记住，这是一个 8 位字符。所以你剩下一个第 8 位，对吧？就像你可以做，抱歉，我说 0 到 120
to 128, so, you know, this includes all the, you know, English letters digits and and symbols and you know most of the things that you're used to printing on the console um those are actually they translate there's there's they're the same character so in other words if you want to print like a lowercase p then whatever the ascii value for that is the utf-8 value is the same thing. And so every ASCII file you have is also a UTF-8 file, right? And so the way they kind of handle that is, you know, you have your 0 to 128. And so remember, this is, you know, an 8-bit character. So you have an 8th bit left over, right? Like you can do, sorry i said zero to 120
实际上是 0 到 127，你只能做 0 到 127，那只需要 7 位，你剩下这个第 8 位。而且你知道，对于常规 ASCII，那将是你的扩展 ASCII 的去处。所以如果第 8 位被设置为真，那么它是一个 128 或更大的数字。他们用它来表示管道和半填充字符，各种各样的奇怪字形，对吧？所以对于 Unicode，如果第 8 位被填充，那告诉 Unicode 引擎这是一个多字节字符。所以文件中的下一个字节或无论它是什么，是当前字符的延续。那将解锁所有其他字符。而且那个想法实际上一直在继续。所以换句话说，即使第二个字节也有那个选项，如果最后一位被设置，那么第二个字节就在说：“嘿，甚至还有另一个字节
it's actually zero to 127 you can do zero to 127 that only that only takes seven bits you have this eighth bit left over and you know with regular ascii that would be where your extended ascii would go so if the eighth bit was set true then it it's a number that's 128 or greater. And they use that to represent pipes and half-filled-in characters, all sorts of kind of weird glyphs, right? So with Unicode, if that eighth bit is filled in, that tells the Unicode engine that this is a multi-byte character. So that next byte in the file or whatever it is, is a continuation of the current character. And that's going to unlock all those other characters. And that idea actually keeps going. So in other words, even the second byte has that option where if that last bit is set, then that second byte is saying, hey there's even another byte
在我后面，它表示更多的字符。”这就是 UTF-8 背后的想法。所以它浪费了一点空间，因为你有所有这些只是告诉你信息的字节，而不是能够表示字符。所以它比 UTF-16 占用更多空间，如果你的很多字符是 16 位的，对吧？但如果你的很多字符只是英文字母
after me that's representing even some more characters. And that's kind of the idea behind UTF-8. And so it wastes a bit of space because you have all these sort of bytes that are just telling you information instead of being able to represent characters. So it takes more because you have all these sort of bytes that are just telling you information instead of being able to represent characters. So it takes more space than like UTF-16 if a bunch of your characters were 16 bit, right? But if a lot of your characters are just English letters
而且只有少数是那种扩展格式，那么你实际上节省了很多，因为在这种情况下，第二个字节会经常是空的。所以这是一种权衡，但能够表示 ASCII 和在显示常规内容（如空格等）时节省字节的结合，使得 UTF-8 完全占据主导地位。所以我的意思是，整个网络超过 90% 的内容要么是 ASCII 要么是 UTF-8。我想另一件要注意的事情是那个假设，我一开始说的，如果你是一个 C 程序员，如果你看……嗯，没有
and only a few of them are sort of that extended format, then you're actually saving a lot because in that case that second byte would be just empty a lot. So it's sort of a trade-off, but the combination of being able to represent ASCII and saving bytes when you're just showing regular things like spaces and whatnot makes UTF-8 just completely dominate. whatnot makes utf-8 just completely dominate so i mean something like over 90 percent of the entire web is in is in either ascii or utf-8 i think the other thing to watch out though is that assumption where i start off with if you're sort of a c programmer if you look at uh well there's no
字符串，但如果你看一个 5 字节的字符数组，包括空终止符，因为我们是优秀的 C 程序员，那不一定是一个 4 个字符长的字符串，对吧？所以这是可能被固化在里面的东西。如果你，你知道，在做格式化并假设，嘿，我的数组里有 5 个东西，我需要为 4 个字符留出空间，那是一种糟糕的假设，因为就像杰森在 UTF-8 中解释的那样，你每个显示的字符可能有多个字节。是的，是的，完全正确。这就是国际化的一部分，理解这种情况可能会发生。是的，你不想尝试自己做 Unicode，就像你不想尝试自己做 Unicode。就像你不想尝试打印 Unicode 字符
strings but if you look at a character array that's five bytes, including the null terminator, because we're good C programmers, that the that the that's not a four necessarily a four character long string, right? So this is something that could get baked in. If you're, you know, doing formatting and assuming that, hey, I have five things in my array, I need to make space for four characters that is you know kind of a bad assumption because like jason was explaining in utf-8 you could have multiple bytes per displayed character yep yeah exactly and that's part of internationalization is understanding that that can happen yeah you don't want to try to do unicode yourself like you don't want to try to do Unicode yourself. Like you don't want to try to print Unicode characters
只使用 printf 之类的东西。那将是一场灾难。是的，我想像一个例子，我从来没做过这个，所以我不知道它是怎么运作的，但我试着凭空想一下。如果你要求用户输入正好 10 个字符的密码，所以你只为那个密码保存了 11 个字节，而有人输入了
using just printf or something like that. It's going to be a disaster. Yeah, I guess like an example, and I've never done this before, so I don't know how it works, but trying to think off the top of my head, I guess. If you required a user to enter exactly a you know 10 character password and so you saved you know only 11 bytes for that password and someone entered and
并且你有能力输入 UTF-8 值，你最终可能会截断那个人的密码，因为你无法保存整个东西。所以是的，那是理解这个假设的一部分，即说：“哦，如果我知道它可以是的最大字符数，那么它可能的最大尺寸是多少？”是的，这很有道理。听起来……我的意思是，我从来没有真正做过底层编程。所以我总是只是传递字符串，并没有真正知道底层有多少字节。但听起来这非常非常困难。
and you had the ability to enter utf-8 values you could end up you know sort of truncating the person's password because you can't save the whole thing right so yeah that's part of understanding this assumption is saying that oh what's the maximum size something can be given if i know the maximum number of characters it can be yeah that makes sense it sounds like um i mean like i've never really done low-level programming. And so I've always just passed strings around, not really knowing how many bytes there were under the hood. But it sounds like this is very, very difficult.
如果你试图自己处理像 C 语言之类的国际化，那可能是一个坏消息。但他们有，我想，Unicode 字符串之类的东西，对吧，即使在 C 语言中。是的，我的意思是，我认为它们只是没有以……我不知道，我不想说“正常方式”，那不是正确的说法。你只需要稍微特别小心，确保你有正确的类型。哦，我明白了。懂了。所以有像 Unicode 字符串 STL 类型之类的东西。
If you're trying to handle a terrestrialization like C or something like that yourself, it's probably going to be bad news bears. But they have, I guess, Un code strings and things like that, right, even in C. Yeah, I mean, I think they're just handled not in the, I don't know, I don't want to say normal way, that's not the quite right way of saying that. You just have to take a little bit of special care to make sure you have the right types. Oh, I see. Got it. So there's like a Unicode string STL type or something.
酷。所以是的，我们将谈论基本上使这变得非常容易的工具。像大多数事情一样，我的意思是，这将是一种共同的主题，但你不想自己做很多这种事情。这是那种已经有几种工具脱颖而出，并占据了，比如说，90% 的国际化工作的事情。它们为你处理所有这些不同的复杂性。如果有一些非常深奥的需求，有人就会进去并在这些库之一中填补那个需求。所以……最著名的是 gettext。gettext 是，如果你运行任何
Cool. So yeah, we'll talk about basically some tools that make this very easy. Like most things, I mean, this is going to be kind of a common motif, but you don't want to be doing a lot of this yourself. This is one of these things that there's been a few tools that have kind of risen to the top and kind of occupy, let's say, 90% of the internationalization effort. And they handle all these different complexities for you. And if there's some very esoteric need someone just goes in and fills that need in in one of these libraries so um the most famous is get text um get text is if you if you run any
类型的 Linux，你已经有了 gettext。在 Linux 机器上没有 gettext 几乎是不可能的。我想即使是 OS X，帕特里克，你可能会纠正我，如果我错了，但我认为即使是 OS X，帕特里克，你可能会纠正我，如果我错了，但我认为即使是 OS X 也有 gettext。我从来没试过，所以我不知道。可能吧。是的，所以我很确定。所以 gettext，它做很多不同的事情，但基本上其中之一是每当你有一个字符串字面量时，所以想象如果你的程序只是说，你知道，cout，括号，括号，你知道，“你好，我是一只狗”之类的，对吧？所以我不知道是什么让我想到那个。所以你用那个字符串字面量做的是，你会放一个下划线括号，
type of linux you already have get text it's almost impossible to not have get text on the linux machine i think even os 10 patrick you'd probably correct me if i'm wrong but I think even OS 10, Patrick, you'd probably correct me if I'm wrong, but I think even OS 10 has get text. I've never tried it, so I don't know. Probably. Yeah, so I'm pretty sure. So get text, it does a bunch of different things, but basically one of the things is whenever you have a string literal, so imagine if your program just says, you know, cout, bracket, bracket, you know, hello, I'm a dog or something, right? So I don't know what made me think of that. So what you do is with that string literal, you would put underscore parentheses,
你会把那个字符串字面量放在括号里。而那实际上会做的是，那将调用一个编译器宏。所以 gettext 有一个编译器宏，那个宏是下划线，所以他们已经采用了那个宏，这将允许我们以某种方式用其他东西替换那个字符串。所以还有很多其他实用程序，它不是（你知道）完全在运行时完成的。但基本上，你可以用这种风格编写代码，我想它是 n 下划线，如果你有一个数字，还有几个其他宏用于不同的（你知道）东西。然后它会生成所谓的 PO 文件，
and you would put that string literal in parentheses. And what that's going to do actually is that's going to invoke a compiler macro so get text has a compiler macro that's the the macro is underscore so they've kind of taken that macro and that is going to allow us to sort of swap out that string with something else and so there's a bunch of other utilities it's not you know entirely done at runtime um but basically you can write your code with this style and i think it's uh it's n underscore if you have a number there's a couple of other macros for different you know things and then uh uh it will uh generate what's called a po file
像一个个性化对象文件。而那将要做的是，它将说：“嘿，这是你输入的字符串。”假设你是一个英语程序员，你会用英语写字符串，比如“你好，我是一只狗”。所以这个 PO 文件将有你用任何语言写的字符串，然后下一行它将有一个占位符，让你用不同的语言放入字符串。所以你将有一个 PO 文件，嗯，假设你用英语写代码，你有一个 PO 文件，嗯，假设你用英语写代码，你有一个 PO 文件，用于法语、荷兰语、德语和所有这些其他语言。而每个 PO 文件都将包含你写的所有字符串。然后在它们之间，只会是，“嘿，我想构建法语版本。”
like a personalization object file and what that's going to do is it's going to say hey here's the string as you put it which let's say you're an English programmer you would write the string in English like hello I'm a dog in English and so this PO file will have your string in whatever language you did and then the next line it'll have a placeholder for you to put the string in a different language so you'll have a PO file for well assuming you're writing the code in English you have a PO file for, well, assuming you're writing the code in English, you have a PO file for French and Dutch and German and all these other languages. And each of those PO files will have all of your strings the way you wrote them. And then in between them, there'll just be, hey, I want to build the French version.
而 gettext 将在构建代码时进行所有这些替换，取决于你的构建系统是如何设置的。所以从这个意义上说，它非常直接。它处理数字。它做得相当好。而且是的，它基本上是标准。所以这是你应该尝试的第一件事。它内置在 Python 中。它有 PHP 和 Java 以及所有其他语言的绑定。而且那是首选的东西。所以如果由于某种原因你不能使用 gettext，看看 ICU。ICU 是，它实际上在 Java 中很常见，使用 ICU 而不是 get
And get text will do all those substitutions as it's building the code, depending on how your build system is set up. So in that sense, it's pretty straightforward. It handles numbers. It does all that pretty well. And yeah, it's basically the standard. So that's the first thing you should try. It's built into Python. It has bindings for PHP and Java and all the other languages. And that's like the go-to thing. So if for whatever reason you can't use GetText, check out ICU. ICU is, it's actually pretty common in Java to use ICU instead of get
text，但这也支持其他语言。是的，这是我能想到的两个大工具。你有没有不得不做任何国际化？我敢肯定我可能……做了相反的事情，我可能在我的代码中做了可怕的、糟糕的假设。我完全一样。不，我不知道，就像它总是我列表上的东西，我应该做得更好。我确实……我们在我之前的一份工作中简要谈过，我们要（你知道）用另一种语言发布一些东西，我们需要（你知道）支持它需要什么。但我们也处于一个资源非常低的设备上，所以（你知道）想到让我们的所有字符串占用两倍的时间，（你知道）两倍的字节，会让我们处于一个非常糟糕的境地。所以我们当时设法不用做它。所以……有道理。但是的，我可以想象它从非常简单到非常复杂。我也……我想
text but this also supports other languages and yeah those are the two big ones I can think of have you ever had to do any uh internationalization i'm sure i'm probably uh done the opposite i've probably done horrible bad assumptions in my code um i am exactly the same way no i i don't know like it's always something i've it's it's forever on my list of i should do better at um i did we did briefly talk about it at my um previous one of my previous jobs that we were gonna you know sort of release some stuff in another language and that we needed to you know what was it going to take to support it but we were also on a very low resource device and so you know the thought of having all of our strings take twice as long you know twice as many bytes would have put us in a really bad spot already so we sort of got away with not having to do it at that time um and so makes sense but yeah i i can imagine it's anything from very simple to very complex um i also i think
哦，请继续。不，不，我要说的是，我的意思是，我们在那个项目上尝试做的另一件事是尽可能消除我们认为不必要的文本。所以使用……那是一个非常好的观点，比如图标而不是文字。是的，是的，这完全有道理。是的，我的意思是，我想，你知道，gettext 的事情非常简单。我想，正如你所说，当你必须处理像从右到左这样的事情时，它会变得困难得多。因为即使，你知道，人们不考虑这一点，但就像，你知道，即使你有关闭按钮
oh go ahead no no i was gonna say i mean the other thing we we tried to do on that project was just eliminate as much text as we could from being necessary so using that's a really good point like icons instead of words yeah Yeah, that totally makes sense. Yeah, I mean, I think, you know, the get text thing is pretty simple. I think, as you said, it gets way harder when you have to deal with like right to left. Because even, you know, people don't think about this, but like, you know, even like you have the close button
在左上角，如果你运行 OS X，无论如何，你有左上角的关闭按钮。如果你处于从右到左模式，那实际上是在右上角。换句话说，它不仅仅是“哦，绘制文本”，它不像反向顺序，但它确实是人们习惯于我们在左边看到的东西，比如目录，所有这些东西，他们习惯于在右边看到它们。所以整个用户体验必须翻转。你知道，几乎就像翻转屏幕，但你不能……你不能只是那样做，因为那样所有的字形都会是反向的。所以它相当复杂。
on the top left, if you're running OS X anyways, you have the close button on the top left. That's actually on the top right. If you're on the right to left mode, like in other words it's not just oh draw the text it's not like reverse order but it's really like people are used to what we're used to seeing on the left like table of contents all those things they're used to seeing those on the right and so the entire user experience has to flip um you know almost like flipping the screen but you can't you can't just do that because then all the glyphs will be backwards so it's pretty complicated
嗯，但是的，我也……我在这个领域几乎什么都没做。我唯一不得不做的事情是处理 gettext 问题，比如当包无法编译之类的事情，因为 gettext。但是的，我的意思是，你知道，它超级重要，尤其是现在人们（你知道）你今天可以在应用商店发布一个应用程序，并在 20 或 30 个不同的国家销售该应用程序。而且有时这很神奇，你知道，有一些东西，比如 Orkut，Orkut 是一个很好的例子，它在巴西非常受欢迎，几乎是随机的。而且那可能会发生在你的应用程序上，你最终可能会发现你最大的市场是不同国家的人。他们不是最终关闭或砍掉了他们吗？
um but yeah i also i've done almost nothing in this space uh the only thing that i've had to do is deal with get text problems like when packages won't compile and things like that because of get text um but yeah i mean it's you know it's super important especially now people are you know you can release an app on the app store today and and sell that app in like 20 or 30 different countries and uh sometimes it's amazing you know there's been things like orc it orc it's a good example of something that's just insanely popular in in brazil kind of almost randomly and uh that could happen to your app and you might end up where your biggest market are are people in a different country didn't they finally shut down or cut them
他们确实关闭了，是的，花了很长时间。所以我不是故意打断你，但是的，我想你是对的，比如在另一个地方变得奇怪地流行。是的，是的，完全是一个很好的问题。我的意思是，只要你有 gettext，那么你就准备好了。酷。所以是的，我想这涵盖了国际化。你知道，作为一个总结，你绝对想要（你知道）研究这些库之一。如果你（你知道）提前知道它们是如何工作的，那真的很有用，因为你可以……即使你不在第一天就进行国际化，你也可以以一种好的方式构建你的应用程序。而且是的，下个月我们会带着我们的奖品赠送活动见到你们。
they did yeah took a very long time so i didn't mean to interrupt you but yeah i think you're right like having a strangely popular in another place thing yeah yeah totally makes a good problem to have yeah i mean as long as you have the get text then you're good to go cool so yeah i think that covers internationalization um you know just a as a summary you definitely want to uh you know look into one of these libraries if you if you know how they work in advance that really is useful because you can kind of even if you don't internationalize on day one you can kind of structure your app in a good way. And yeah, we'll see you guys next month with our prize giveaway.
他们确实花了很长时间，我不是有意打断你，但我觉得你说得对，在其他地方意外地受欢迎确实是一个幸福的烦恼。只要你做好了文本提取，那就没问题了。好的，我想关于国际化就讲到这里。总之，你一定要去研究一下这些库。如果你能提前了解它们的工作原理会非常有帮助，因为这样即使你第一天没有进行国际化，也能以一种良好的方式构建你的应用。好了，下个月的奖品赠送活动再见。
We'll go live for that. And I'll give you more details about that later on. Hey, this is Patrick in the editing bay. We got some submissions for new theme songs. so we're trying them out as outros. This first one is The Tube by Parker Knight. Thank you. Teksting av Nicolai Winther Thank you. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将对此进行直播。稍后我会为您提供更多相关细节。嘿，我是剪辑室里的帕特里克。我们收到了一些新主题曲的投稿，所以我们正在尝试将它们用作片尾曲。第一首是帕克·奈特的《The Tube》。谢谢。字幕由尼古拉·温特制作。谢谢。开场音乐是比纳尔·派洛特的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议下发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，也可以进行重混和改编，但必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。